we're on our way to a safe house to meet
one of Iran's protest leaders Kawa is a
Young Man Slightly built and quietly
spoken with a few definable features
that he is insistent we disguise
understandably so he is a wanted man in
Iran and the threat of prison and
torture is unthinkable
how was
morale amongst your fellow protesters
foreign
the morale is very high and they're
waiting looking for a window to come
back onto the streets anything small
that happens will bring people back onto
the streets
[Applause]
Carla was on the streets the night that
this happened
three protesters were killed and many
wounded
foreign
they had to move fast before the regime
got hold of the bodies
people went to both hospitals so that
the corpses would not be seized by the
regime the people went and took custody
of the bodies
they brought a body to the mosque to
wash it and bury it at that moment the
regime fired on the mosque
there were women and children I did not
see anyone wearing military fatigues the
way they shot at us it was like they
were attacking an armed group but we
were civilians
[Music]
foreign as one of the protests leaders
how vulnerable do you feel
good
I feel very much under watch and at
night I'm always ready to flee if they
raid our house I've prepared everything
how do you feel about going back
I feel it's my responsibility to go back
and resume my activities until people
are free
yeah this is evidence that Iranian
forces are using shotguns against
protesters who have been given this
video of one man with hundreds of
pellets embedded in his arm and body he
is being treated in an apartment if they
go to hospital the Protestants are
immediately exposed as being part of the
anti-government movement and so doctors
sympathetic to the demonstrations visit
them in secret the doctors have to
smuggle medicine out of the hospitals
because like the protesters they too are
risking their lives
[Music]
if these secret Medical Teams were not
available most of the Wounded would most
likely die some whose medical situations
were not good had to have their hands or
arms amputated
it's evident that there is an extensive
underground Network supporting the
anti-government street protests both
sides are hardening their positions
neither side will give in more violence
is inevitable
Alistair bunker Sky News in Northern
Iraq